are these multiple billboard awards
getting heavy for you absolutely
absolutely you know what i'm saying i'm
getting my workout on but you know
you know this is a good workout to get
give me a little just a couple curls
with those you know
i'm like 200 and since i've grabbed my
ain't stopped since i got them you see
what i'm saying i'm trying i'm trying to
get right i'm trying to get summerslam
sexy
so we're getting summertime sexy you
know i mean live at the billboard music
awards that's how we rock it
it's amazing i'm going to start doing
that get my hot girl summer going yes
exactly if i can borrow them
exactly yeah you can you can't it's all
good
you got two of them i mean how does that
feel to say multiple
i like the show i'll take you up on it
because you have multiple multiple
billboard music awards how does that
feel
it feels amazing there's nothing short
of a blessing man to receive the fruits
of my labor
you know what i'm saying me and my team
everybody around me man we work hard you
know i mean i
stopped 366 days out of the year so you
know to get what we deserve man it's not
sort of a blessing i mean right now you
have some of the catchiest songs out
there
and now you're here with these
incredible artists is there anybody who
you wanted to meet tonight
any they have so many uses the billboard
music awards
anybody you wanted to meet tonight we
got drake pink dj khaled here
i'm excited to see everybody man i'm
excited to see my peers you know i mean
be honored for their hard work as well
you know i probably enjoy that more than
i enjoy myself getting trophies you know
i'm saying because i know we all work
hard and i know what it takes to
you know to get to places like this i
know the sacrifices and the work put
into it so i'm just excited to see
everybody out
you know what i mean and just you know
enjoying myself i
i don't know i read tell me if i'm wrong
but i read that you just surpassed drake
in monthly
streams on spotify i heard about it
well you mentioned that to drake tonight
my daughter my daughter taught me how to
do that little dance where
she going she going like that she see me
doing a little tv but um is she watching
at home i hope so
i heard about it though you know and you
know being to be in conversation
or you know in the same sentence when we
talk about
the amount of spotify listeners you got
with somebody you know as talented
and successful as drake is nice sort of
a blessing man i'm here to do what i'm
supposed to do
i mean that's how i rock who's watching
at home tonight your daughter any family
supporting you and how does that feel
my my pretty mama they gave me this this
pretty smile that i'm gonna show y'all
take your time looking at it and i'm
showing the other side my pretty mama
what's up baby i love you
you know what i'm saying i love you the
i'm bringing them to you right now
i love that you're taking this moment
for mom not for show show that's what we
do
that's what we do well what's next for
you oh man uh
we'll be right back on billboard hot 100
number one
no later than uh i mean number two right
now
we'll do a little levitate you know
you're probably number one again right
number one
do a leap of congratulations you know
what i'm saying we you know so
i mean i don't even know what we talking
about baby's amazing
who do you want to collab with who's on
the list um everybody anybody just going
crazy working hard man drake i'm i'm
waiting on you
my boy he's here tonight he's getting
that important ain't dead you know
we still ain't got in that blender man
i'm waiting on you man you know what i'm
saying i'm waiting on you
you know i've been waiting on a good
time but uh it's a lot of people man
i'll be honored to work with anybody
that's out here really you know doing
their own thing unapologetically
you know putting that work in to get to
where they're trying to go to well i
know i have to let you go and celebrate
but who who's this look by who are you
wearing
this look is about baby you know i most
definitely put this together i just had
it laying around in my closet i had the
uh
the taylor pull up on me and make a
little a couple alterations to it but
this is a suede gucci
gucci two-piece suit you know what i'm
saying suede
i complimented it with a with a hot pink
louis vuitton belt
the compliment to keith james for doing
hat then i'm showing you right here you
see that one
okay cool you know and then i write them
to sleep with a pink turtleneck the
turtleneck is gucci by the way
you know i mean so all the fabric it
feels real nice on my skin and i hope it
looks real
good on your tv screens and i appreciate
y'all for having me this is the best
interview i've ever done thank you
you